qué queda Por sancionar qué falta por
por sancionar en Rusia donde ya vemos
que llevamos una cascada de sanciones
enorme sí efectivamente han sido muchas
las sanciones de hecho ningún país ha
sido sancionado de esta manera como le
está haciendo ahora la Unión Europea
hacia Rusia Qué falta por solucionar
pues sin duda el petróleo que todavía no
está sancionado se ha sancionado el
gasto todavía no el petróleo porque la
Unión Europea sabe que no tiene esta
autonomía energética que le permitiría
tomar esta sanción
otra vez vemos Que Hay ciertos sectores
de la industria rusa que ha sido
afectado esencialmente el automóvil hoy
en día Rusia Está sacando automóviles
que no tiene un sistema de freno de abcn
que no tiene estos airbags porque le
hace falta la tecnología que se puede
sancionar más se va a cerrar Más aún el
sistema financiero y sin duda van a
tener que regular más aún las
exportaciones de hidrocarburos pero como
estamos viendo Rusia ya está mirando por
otro lado para exportar y precisamente
uno de los lados a los que está mirando
es hacia china e India con las cuales
al obtener un alivio en esa presión que
occidente está imponiendo con los
hidrocarburos Daniela cuéntenos un poco
más de estas crisis energéticas que está
pasando y cómo Rusia está haciendo el
frente pues mire el sufrimiento para la
economía mundial ha sido generalizado ya
lo sabemos suministro reducidos de
cereales y granos también fertilizantes
y energía junto con más inflación e
incertidumbre económica se podría hacer
como el panorama general a pesar de que
el mundo ya estaba lidiando con ambos
por cuenta de la pandemia ahora Rusia
suministraba Entonces el 40% de las
necesidades energéticas de la Unión
Europea con la invasión y las
posteriores sanciones el continente se
enfrentó a ese desafío de descubrir cómo
iba a reemplazar rápidamente ese gas y
petróleo rusos que todos los años pues
mantenían o protegían a las viviendas o
a las familias del invierno a nivel
mundial el primer impacto se sufrió
cuando el petróleo subió levemente a 139
dólares el barril el año pasado volvió a
caer alrededor de 80 dólares por barril
después de que quedó claro que como dice
Eugene
de las sanciones occidentales sobre el
volumen de las exportaciones de Moscú
pues había sido más bien limitado y Cuál
es la situación Daniela hoy un año luego
de la invasión de la de Rusia a Ucrania
entonces Europa ha conseguido nuevos
vendedores y Moscú nuevos compradores
como decía María Clara para sus
productos energéticos que son el alma de
su economía por ejemplo en Asia China o
India que le compran petróleo con un
buen descuento y ha mantenido el
suministro de bienes de consumo a través
de un esquema de importaciones que ha
sido bastante criticado porque permite
ingresar productos al país sin la
autorización del fabricante original
también se están aislando mutuamente con
los mercados occidentales que le
ayudaron también a impulsar su
crecimiento después de la caída de la
unión soviética y háganos un repaso de
Qué ha pasado con estos precios pues
miren los precios del gas como vamos a
ver a continuación han caído hasta un
85% desde que alcanzaron un punto máximo
en verano estábamos en precios de Entre
10 20 euros por megavatio hora en enero
de 2020 fueron subiendo y ya para la
invasión se dispararon hasta los 300 más
allá de 300 por mega 300 euros por
megavatio hora desde entonces ha venido
bajando
pues ha venido bajando hasta entre los
50 euros por megavatios hora
aproximadamente y ahora el problema
estos inclusive antes menos de lo que
está de que antes de que estallara el
conflicto los gobiernos europeos cuál es
el problema que los gobiernos europeos
han tenido que gastar casi 800 mil
millones de euros en subsidios de
energía para los hogares Y para las
empresas y se están preguntando cuánto
tiempo pueden mantener cuánto tiempo
pueden mantenerse entonces subsidiando
la energía a la gente no mucho más y
creo que los gobiernos de Europa han
sido bastante claros sobre eso Por
ejemplo en Francia del gobierno macu ha
dicho que el bucle es decir el escudo
tarifario en el cual había un bloqueo
del precios de la energía para que no
pasara una cierta un cierto precio ya se
va a acabar Durante los los últimos
meses las facturas tanto de energía de
gas de Electricidad han subido un 20% Y
es probable ha anunciado ya el gobierno
mccon que suban de un 15% cada mes yo
quiero hacerle una pregunta porque si
bien un poco la estrategia de Rusia como
lo estábamos viendo era ahogar a
occidente a través de los precios del
gas que es una de las tres
características que se requiere para
este hidrocarburo y es la accesibilidad
esta vez mediante el precio hacer que
los precios suban como nos lo estaba
mostrando Daniela Pero por otra parte
occidente ha respondido imponiéndole
límites a los crudos al crudo ruso
inicialmente lo hizo el g7 y Australia
en diciembre de 2022 que prohibió que
cualquier barril ruso que valiera más de
60 dólares y entrara a la Unión Europea
o a los países miembros del g7 o
circulará incluso por sus mares y luego
en febrero de 2023 la Unión Europea
decide tomar una sanción similar que
tanto ha afectado esto Rusia Bueno lo ha
afectado muy de manera muy limitado
porque finalmente como dijimos ya Rusia
se estaba buscando nuevos socios
entonces lo que se perdía por un lado se
está ganando por otro lado Entonces está
exportando hacia china hacia India hacia
Turquía hacia incluso al geria entonces
ahí Rusia no tiene tanto problemas como
tiene la Unión Europea que realmente se
dio cuenta que soberanía energética no
tiene y que ya está trabajando No
Solamente sobre unos nuevos socios que
los podría brindar esta esta energía
pero también están preparando la
transición energética no solamente por
razones económicas y ecológicas pero
también porque se dan cuenta que no
tienen otra opción una de las
consecuencias más problemáticas no de la
guerra en Ucrania ha sido la crisis
alimentaria Daniela Sí Santiago antes de
la guerra Ucrania y Rusia ostentaban
casi una tercera parte de las
exportaciones mundiales de trigo una
quinta parte del Maíz y un 80% del
aceite de gira también eran los
principales proveedores mundiales Y eso
hay que hacer énfasis de África Oriente
medio y partes de Asia y allá ya muchos
estaban luchando históricamente contra
la inseguridad alimentaria Rusia también
era su principal proveedor de
fertilizantes y la guerra interrumpió
todo eso tenemos casos concretos de
países afectados Como por ejemplo Egipto
que es el importador número uno de trigo
del mundo
cómo ha sido Entonces esta crisis para
estos países y se ve al corto plazo que
puedan superarla Bueno lo más importante
no es el corto plazo sino que va a ser
el largo plazo porque estamos
efectivamente en un escenario en el cual
no hay soberanía alimentaria Y eso
sabemos que puedes desencadenar en
varios problemáticas inestabilidad
política
refugiados
todo una un conjunto de factores que
pueden desestabilizar a la a la a la
región Entonces eso es un problema sin
embargo miramos que Ucrania por ejemplo
que estaba
5 millones de toneladas al mes hoy en
día está en la posibilidad de exportar
sobre solamente uno punto cinco millones
de toneladas al mes eso es un problema
lo hemos visto genera inflación en la
Unión Europea todavía está controlado
por los organismos como la FAO
internacionales que se pueden que pueden
comprar en los mercados internacionales
pero el problema es que empiezan a tener
efectivamente problemas para encontrar
todos estos insumos en los mercados
mundiales así que sin duda el reto no es
tanto a corto plazo sino más bien a
largo